hey guys Pete here the other day I saw
the survey from reddit that sort of blew
my mind so I wanted to make a quick
video to look at the results the survey
was posted by the user feisty potato it
had 5,400 responses and instead of just
posting the results for each question
feisty made a nice infographic can
pointed out some interesting connections
I'll post a link to the original reddit
post in the description so you can go
and look at some of the feedback that
the results got as a reminder my book
giveaway is still going on so make sure
you stick around to the end of the video
to learn more about that now let's jump
right into it the survey is titled
predictions and speculation for the
winds of winter and the future of a song
of ice and fire the questions are no
longer live since the voting is closed
but you get a general idea what they
were from the answers the first bit of
data we get is when do you believe the
winds of winter will be published the
majority of those surveyed nearly
sixty-five percent agree it will come
out in 2017 with 2018 coming in second
with twenty-five percent this is a fair
assumption considering that most fans
expected that we would get the book
before season six based on georgia's own
predictions and since 2016 is almost
over it doesn't look good that will get
it this year I don't really get the
motivation behind the ones who voted
2018 I think collectively we're all
disappointed that the book hasn't been
released yet but it also we give George
the benefit of the doubt since when
thinking clearly we know it'll be worth
the wait 2018 just seems like an
arbitrary answer in that sense maybe to
be on the safe side or something but I
think most people who answered out of
frustration picked that it would never
come out which got a crazy high four
point three percent personally I think
the chances of winds never coming out or
zero since the majority of the book must
be written by now a dream of spring is a
different story but we'll get to that a
little bit later in the survey an
interesting point here is that people
also gave an answer as to what quarter
of the year would be coming out the
majority prediction overall is the
second quarter which is april may and
june of 2017 if you've been waiting and
wondering when the book might come out
think spring of 2017 this seems
realistic to me just based on the amount
of time between the last two releases
which is the strong indication of how
long it takes him to get a book done the
next bit of data is how many years after
publication of the winds of winter will
it take for a dream of spring to be
published the stat that jumps out to me
here is that 21.2 percent answered never
twenty percent would be one out of every
five people pulled what seemed super
high to me I guess I've always had it in
the back of my mind that it's possible
the final book wouldn't get finished but
I don't think I'd ever vote that way
keep in mind that even though this is
the highest individual answer it means
that nearly eighty percent of people
answered that it would actually come out
the positive answers are just spread out
over different lengths of time in
general most of the answers are from
four to seven years with an overall
average of five point five four this
seems like a good educated guess to me
and I expect this is the way things will
turn out so if you think winds will be
out early next year that means a dream
of spring will be dropping in the winter
of 20 22 it sounds so long from now when
you say it like that but let's remember
that building worlds and writing great
stories isn't something that happens
overnight to go along with this we get
the most common responses as to why some
people believe a dream of spring won't
be published they include george RR
martin is old he's losing interest
lacking motivation george RR martin will
die he's slowing down and that he has a
slow writing pace first of all George
just had a birthday and turned 68 that's
not that old the average life expectancy
for men in the u.s. is around 75 with a
number of factors that could make that
higher the answer that he's losing
interest is the dumbest answer in my
opinion because a lot of things can
happen to slow down a creative process
but losing interest in the story you've
been thinking about for more than 20
years just isn't one of them in my
opinion wanted to take a break have a
hiatus work on something else so on and
so forth those are all reasonable
reasonable things that could pop up but
it's not like he doesn't work on other
projects concurrently I think stress is
a very real part of this process but I
can't see him losing interest in doing
what pretty much every writer sets out
to do in their lifetime this series is
his magnum opus he is slowing down has
some validity to it since I can imagine
that ending a story like this is pretty
daunting overall once you're going you
know once you hit the end it's probably
hard to wrap things up but I'm in the
camp of thinking that taking a little
more time will pay dividends to the
reader so this doesn't really
bother me slow writing pays well that is
what it is every writer is different so
most of us have been waiting for a long
time for the release of wind so we'll
just have to wait until it's done george
RR martin will die is a frightening
answer that i don't really want to think
about honestly like I said he isn't that
old and as far as I can tell all of his
faculties are intact I can see if he was
like 95 or even 88 but this is just
isn't something that seems likely it
would be unfortunate if something would
happen to his health but it's not the
sort of thing we need to worry about
last two sections of the graphic or
about whether a dream of spring will be
the last book in the series seventy
percent of people answered yes and I
tend to agree obviously the series could
be enjoyable for fans no matter how many
books there end up being but I tend to
think that the author would like to
finish we know he has other song of ice
and fire related works he wants to
complete and he has mentioned wanting to
write other genres as well I don't think
money prestige fame or anything else
really factors into it anymore at this
point he had a story in mind and the
most reasonable thing for him to do is
to complete it of the thirty percent of
people who don't think it will be the
last book the most common responses are
too much to write and wrap up there's
still money to be made it will be split
into two books george RR martin is bad
at predictions this was originally
supposed to be a trilogy after all none
of these answers are outside the realm
of possibility but i still think he is
at the point of wanting to finish part
of me thinks that coming up with new
ideas isn't the problem but instead
staying out of the weeds and just
heading straight to the finish line is
we have some evidence of this with the
last two books and the subsequent winds
of winter preview chapters we've seen
but overall I don't think he will run
into the same problem again and again I
guess it is possible that he might have
to chop dreams into two books but I
wouldn't expect that to happen unless
he's already written a bunch of chapters
for it at this point for those who
thought it wouldn't be the last book
57.7 percent said that they thought it
would get finished and forty two point
three percent said no the most common
answers here seemed to be the basically
the same as the people who thought the
winds would never come out in the first
place since I don't think he will add
another book to the series I can't
really offer much on this the last
section of the infographic gives a nice
overview on when the people surveyed
started reading the series if you're
wondering why there is such a big spike
in 2000
and while it's because that's when Game
of Thrones first aired on HBO the last
thing at the bottom tells us there was
no observable correlation between the
length of time participants had been a
fan and the predictions they made for
the release of winds of winter and a
dream of spring this means based on the
data that older a song of ice and fire
fans are no more pessimistic nor
optimistic than newer faint so what do
you guys think let me know in the
comments if you've been waiting for the
book and what you think will happen do
you think when the winner will be out
before Game of Thrones Season seven how
about a dream of spring do you think
it's going to be the same amount of time
we're going to wait or do you think that
it might come out a little bit faster or
if you're a complete du mer do you think
it'll never come up please like the
video if you think it's likable I
appreciate all the feedback I've been
getting and want to welcome all the new
subscribers I had a couple of people ask
me about a patreon account through my
Twitter so I'm thinking about starting
one let me know what you guys think if
you think it's a good idea thing with
patreon is it's great but it's hard to
get it started you know patreon that has
supporters obviously does better than
one that doesn't so I'm kind of like
button hesitant to start one without
much interest in now that I have some
interest i'm thinking more about doing
it also we're getting close to the
giveaway goal if you're not a subscriber
please subscribe now for your chance to
win i'm giving one of you guys a free
copy of the night of the Seven Kingdoms
when I hit eighteen thousand subscribers
all you have to do is leave a comment
but likes are also appreciated what I'll
do is I'll use one of the youtube
comment pickers that are out there I'll
search through the videos I've made
since the giveaway started and pick one
comment from each of those videos from
there I'll take all those names and pick
the final winner at random so
technically you can enter more than once
by going back and watching older videos
and leaving comments just don't be the
guy who spams out in the comments
without ever watching the videos nobody
likes that guy trust me just watch the
video and leave comments and for that
I'll wish you good luck in the giveaway
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon